I recently created my own online college
Conan State University why you asked
that I started college I did it for the
sole purpose of feeling a basketball
team that could potentially break into
the NCAA Final Four here in Atlanta and
thanks to AT&T we were able to assemble
our teams super fast then I ran into a
small roadblock you see I found out we
aren't eligible for the NC double-a
tournament yes I agree
something about rules we also weren't
eligible for the NIT tournament but
fortunately yes I agree boo again but
fortunately we were eligible for the
East San Fernando Valley rented gym
Invitational Tournament
justice finally served their there we
met Glendale Community College for the
coveted es fvr GI t championship it was
a great game here are the highlights I
put together the finest Conan State team
ever to play in the school's two-week
history
staff members like number six Aaron
Blair are Wepner number six pierre
bernard graphics nerve number six Matt
Kramer production coordinator and nerd
number six Levon behind number six
choose the robot who two weeks ago was a
sorbet machine and number six James
Worthy will Pratley played on a team
called the Los Angeles Lakers which I
assume is the Clippers farm team and
rooting for them all the fighting
underachievers team mascot our opponent
the Glendale Community College women's
basketball team
[Music]
[Music]
some questioned my decision to keep a
seven-time NBA all-star on the bench but
I knew exactly what I was doing
get the ball the shoots shoots from
downtown three-pointer
bringing down shirts you can't even move
it's just that your hamstring you're
finished you're done for the game okay
and guys shoots is out of the game I'm
not thrilled about this but James I
think you're gonna be playing now okay
well let's see how you do all right
but first I don't want you taking a lot
of shots I want you to support the core
okay as I suspected where these presents
made no difference whatsoever but
fortunately I had a secret weapon
but before I could even touch the ball
my phone rang hey Andy what's going on
[Music]
okay I'll try to work it in oh and Andy
I hate to tell you this but shoots the
robot he got hurt he got hurt real bad
Conan am I going to be okay
[Applause]
inspired by the memory of shoes a team
finally found its rhythm and the crowd
was going wild but we were still well
behind at the Hat now listen up we still
have two quarters left if we work really
hard we show some hustle and some
teamwork we could win I'm of the opinion
it's not worth it and we should quit now
who's with me quick let's get out okay
bleh how long would it take you to
dissolve our online university before
clicks all right get rid of it
James okay what are you driving Subaru
has bad okay would we all fit you think
absolutely okay let's get
[Applause]
you